[Music]  over 2000 years ago the city of genuan  was built on a natural moat  sandwiched between mountains intending  to keep intruders out  but today tourists flow through the  streets of the famous venice of the  orient  built in 205 bc during the qin dynasty  the wu yong river divides the city into  two parts  east  and west  numerous small canals rivers and bridges  dot the landscape of this ancient city  the city also thrived from trade the  silk road of the south went through this  city because it was the only access  point by ship from south china to the  central plains  merchant ships were docked here from  vietnam thailand and india eager to move  through the port to the capital  today you will find remnants of old and  new married perfectly in this ancient  city  as day turns to night the stunning views  turn into a neon wonderland  [Music]  you